hello and welcome to this video playing
martin
1000 mg
okay i can also
write a short hi he's playing
rather quickly um
play b3 here right yeah
okay so we just transpose him
to fairly regular looking
semi-sloth
okay i can't castle here right
it's losing lots of time here with this
opening play
queen c2 maybe i'm not quite sure what
he what his
intention is here really he
cannot set up a stone ball that is
already gone
this option and he doesn't get in c5 or
e5
okay so
knight e5 is is possible
yeah i guess this is a good move
prevents also b6 for the moment
i guess f4 that's that's what i
had in mind
okay um the question
that i have is that move actually
possible a tick on d5
e takes knight takes c6
it's a typical tactic there i know it
has knight b6 at the end
okay okay okay okay
so it doesn't work
yeah so but what are we going to play a
c5
or prepare
a later g4 or i could also just retreat
take on d7 and c5 is
that's a little bit stodgy i don't want
that so go c5
but maybe maybe it's not so bad to get
rid of
the knight
you can text with this
ship d4 a4 b5
wow really that take queen takes and
then there's there's two
no it's still very good for wide yeah
let's take
queen b4 and i take c6
it's very good for white
very good is actually
euphemism where is the bishop even going
to b7
i can play rook b1 first
queen a3
i can take e6 though yeah so i'm just
winning uh winning the house
[Music]
bishop takes f5 is also possible but
rook b1
what about the b7 bishop
so i take b7 queen d3
okay he found the
resigns button it was a bit of an odd
opening play
i mean if you lose all that time here
with the check
you should at least play a five
it's not a good stone wall but at least
um then the whole time invested here
led to a structural change the knight
df6
just loses an enormous amount of time
so yeah this is pretty um
difficult already to play
as this bishop on c8 is not getting out
knight e5 knight d7 f4
f5 stops this i was briefly thinking
about
the capture because
this can sometimes be an idea but in
this particular case
the knight here is just it's covering
everything
and that makes yes he takes i mean okay
i have
this or bishop f5 maybe
yeah okay c5 you have so many good moves
here c5
took this and
now yeah your b5 is
probably not good
it's also i mean i can just go a4 which
is great
as well yeah
the capture is actually not liked by the
computer at
all because bishop takes b4 seems to be
possible
let's that's uh it would have been a bit
of a cold shower here
i mean a4 is good because he cannot go
a6 yeah this is just
not working
yeah but okay bishop before i didn't see
that at all
that's bad yeah because we're taking now
queen takes is perfectly okay i guess
yeah
i can take here but bishop c5 i thought
takes on e3 is already good
well that is not clear at all
that's probably why he didn't do it yeah
this this was irritated but he can't
even do this
oh wow yeah okay
my capture on b6 is was just bad bishop
takes before i didn't have on the radar
at all
after this i'm probably uh a lot better
i am
yeah after the capture is over he has to
go
to seven or something like that
queen b7 okay so rook b won
first and then taking is better even so
i didn't really punish
his play to the fullest not at all
actually
that was a good move no didn't see it at
all
okay guys thanks for watching